brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza
but then just imagine this amazing deal
that you want to do but we turn it into
a moneymaking machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys phasm is very simple but now we
know it's not
simple in every single strand of DNA
there's three billion
Bas and your DNA has more information
than any library in the world
that
information is specified it's complex so
it's not just the words Max like a name
is commands for example I'll give you an
example my friend
here we're talking about DNA we take
seen on tv YouTube we take out his DNA
we take out his DNA yeah when we take
out his DNA yeah that strand of
information yeah is is so incredible
that you could actually store all of the
books from the British Library into that
strength easily wow so what does it show
you intelligence right it's not to do
with time because time will lead to
chaos if you see if you give it a
billion years unless someone's tinkering
with the process yeah you see I I'll
tell you something interesting you know
Charles Darwin himself yes he came up
with the theory of evolution yes did you
know that when he published his theory
he still believed in God yeah I guess he
did he was a deist yeah yeah when he
published his theory in 1858 at the
Royal Society here in London he still
believed in God later on in his life he
became an agnostic because of the
problem of evil oh yeah yeah yeah right
know all right that's a problem okay
however he said in my wildest
fluctuations these are his words I was
never an atheist so people think
evolution yeah explains God no if I was
to explain to you how your car Works how
it works you put in petrol you get
combustion you get electricity you get
Windows you get that's the how it
doesn't explain the why so Evolution
even at best is a how explanation not a
why explanation yeah it's a bit like AI
for example the information that say hi
Max Max
Ali I'm your yeah it's like AI the
information that we give to AI gives us
different results when we ask them
questions it deres information different
places so the credit is not given to the
AI it's given to the people that made it
so the question is the first that was
made it had those properties even if you
go argument sake that what we have today
different species and all that kind of
stuff if he all goes back to the first
cell that means the first had the
properties to bring forth back to
life so therefore it points of why
because for example AI yeah when you use
AI yeah do you not say AI is quite
intelligent yes okay we created it okay
do you thank the AI or the people that
made the
AI
uh I thank the people that made the AI
okay good so where saying instead of
thanking the celf thank the one that
made the cell okay okay so you think
that the cell was created that's you
think no no I think that's what it is
okay exactly unless yeah exactly that's
what we talking about I don't think that
I don't think that that was created then
what's what's your evidence to that cuz
you need to tell us why you believe the
first cell came out to be then we can
have a dialogue I don't have to tell you
I can't course you do come on can I what
I can tell you is that I'm not sure I'm
not like I have I don't have any idea of
why and how it come but I can tell you
that and say that and be comfortable
like I don't have to know no you do you
know why how do you know you're not in
the Matrix M now how do you know I exist
how do you know I'm real how do you know
you're real I have no idea okay okay no
problem but look there are I can I can
you mind I don't I don't want to be done
for assault but can I do you mind yeah
of course okay are you feeling that yeah
exactly okay are you feeling that but is
that real yeah yeah okay so that is real
I think it's real oh you think it's real
my mind think it's real so would you
allow somebody to get a gun into your
head and say let's just test if you're
real or not of course not why not but
why do you say why don't you just test
it cuz you're not
certain because because you are certain
that you will lose your life and this is
what we say when it comes to this issue
when you're crossing the road you look
left and right because you're not going
to say maybe it's the Matrix maybe if I
go the bus will just go past me like
Matrix you know do his bullet yeah when
it comes to God this is what I try to
understand Max why is it when it comes
to God rationality and logic goes out
the window but when it comes to you
waking up in the morning you know you're
in your house you know when you go to
your fridge you know where the eggs are
you know everything's rational
everything is logical if you went to
your fridge and saw a bunny rabbit
you'll be that's bizarre you never say
possibility is rational I put it that
way no but if you went to your if you
went to your fridge and opened and saw a
rocket yeah what's a rocket doing in my
fridge I put it there somebody put it
there good The Logical rational thing
you come to is what some body you
wouldn't say random chances of you would
say something must have put it there so
what we're saying is the following the
first cell someone must have put because
when you say I don't know I don't know
is a cop out because you don't apply
that to your day-to-day life you came
here today what's your what's the reason
you're out to you going to clubing party
I'm from Sweden you're from Sweden yeah
so why did what's the reason you came to
the uh in London to work for work so you
know you came here for a reason you were
certain you didn't say I'm uncertain for
where I'm going that's our argument okay
okay so so this rocket thing yeah so if
why I would have a fridge it was closed
for a million a thousand a million years
and the molecules for building a rocket
actually existed in that fridge yes it
will be in rocket at one one point
because that's what chance
happens can I just ask one small Point
yeah you know when you're playing
snooker or pool yeah exactly when you
hit the white ball it hits the red ball
exactly does it go in random directions
or does it or do you or can you tell
which directions it's going go exctly
but but that's not the point that's not
the same think right the same argum I'm
asking a different question which is is
it random or is it non-random no it's
because you you you have a direction you
have a like force momentum in that way
and then you send the ball that way and
it kicks another ball in the same
direction true it's about momentum right
yeah so if if I if I was to ask you max
if you know you're going to hit the ball
you know the velocity you know the
surface friction you know the atmosphere
you know all of down to the quantum
mechanics can you predict where all the
balls are going to go if you know
everything of course of course good
so even if evolution is the process by
which we were created it's certainly not
random CU Randomness doesn't exist yeah
why not there is no chance in sence
because Randomness is a term for our
ignorance okay we're playing we're
playing snook we're playing snooker and
I hit the ball Ali says it went randomly
exactly but then I say to Ali it's not
random because if we knew everything
about the parameters the constraints we
would know where all the Bulls go you
know the so everything is determined did
you understand he's saying look look
look heads and tails yeah the reason
there is no chance in science meaning
the following when the reason we say
chance to heads and tails is because we
do not know all the factors that
determine heads or tails if we knew the
wind the angle I throw it at the power
that I use if we knew precisely we would
know exactly the same results every
single time the only reason we call it
chance is because we do not know the
factors so he's saying with evolution is
the same thing there is no such thing as
because if when you know all the factors
it is all determined that's why there
are people who are hard determinists
exactly do you get what I'm trying to
say so there is no chance ex
design I don't agree with that no but on
what basis so the basis is that we if we
would know so I agree totally agree with
it if we knew everything we would knew
exactly what would happen to the ball
where it would go yes I agree with that
uh but the thing is that so we would
know that if we have all the molecules
if we have this kind of
and then we take it we fast forward
million years then these molecules let
one point Come Together okay but you
need to have molecules in the first
place look the molecules have to be
there in the first place if I if I have
an empty cop exactly and we give it
billions of years would I ever get a
Ferrari yes probably no no no you would
no no no no it's good live now you would
never get a Ferrari cuz the components
to make a Ferrari is not in the cup so
time is IR chance time is irrelevant to
equation if the elements to make a
Ferrari are not in the cup if you have a
cup that's completely closed empty not
empty I'm not even talking about items
there is nothing there what's time got
to do with a Ferrari being made when the
elements to make it is not there but the
elements were created like in the in I'm
saying there are no elements good good
so we will not get a Ferrari so then the
point the question is this who put the
elements there for it
to be um make what we have today nobody
okay so then okay nothing so then it
came from nothing
yeah Max you're an intelligent guy
you're a clever guy Max Max max0 equals
one zero from nothing nothing the
universe is that we're trying to
understand it no no I'm asking you a
question rational logical can something
come from nothing rational logically
ration with my human logic where I was
born like I'm born this I have the the
brain that I can use and it's it's it's
actually made to function in the African
Savannah and stuff like that I can't
rationally understand that nothing that
something can come from nothing I'm
asking you can I agree can it it
probably can OB I think it can but I
don't I don't give me one example of
something coming from nothing one the
thing is like why do we we because we
build our like idea of how we we are
living on our earth now like we build
our like our thoughts and everything
from from our world yes because that's
how experience but but why does it that
have to be true maybe there's another
explain something else but the thing is
whatever explained to be a God no no no
problem I'm saying why why is there an
allergy towards god let's say aliens the
point is this there was there has to be
a prior cause to
that I don't I don't okay but can
something come from nothing simple
question can zero equal one I don't
know just think about look nothing is
the absence of something how could you
get something from nothing I don't know
this is the thing but you do know when
came out here that's the double standard
that but that's that's what the science
people say know can are you uncertain
about everything uncertain about
everything it sounds like you're
uncertain about everything you don't
know anything for
certain um at some point yes but at some
point no okay so if I to ask you are you
in doubt that you're
thinking uh no I'm not I'm not in doubt
but I mean like it's a cool philosopher
to think that might be like a but the
the whole point of this thought
experiment is to show that you can't
that you are thinking you know day
cart's famous idea of I think therefore
I am exactly exactly you will always go
back to some things which are immovable
they're factual and you can't doubt them
for example you can think I may be in a
matrix but you cannot think I do not
exist I'm thinking minimum
okay something exists rather than
nothing we agree about this me and you
agree I don't know maybe well you exist
yeah
okay and you're thinking so clearly we
exist rather than not exist okay so now
there's two options either something
came from nothing or something came from
something but that's something must have
come for something okay if we say that
something came from something and we ask
that question again and again and again
and again can it go back
forever it have to if if if that's the
point that we're making that something
has to be created by something then
that's what we have to do and that's why
I think it's not true because something
something needs to be like the beginning
and I think that's the universe okay
okay interesting think okay you you made
a brilliant point which is it has to
stop somewhere or else we or else we
wouldn't exist that's God right well
actually no before we get to God the
first thinker to realize this was
Aristotle so he came up with the idea of
foundationalism that everything has to
start off with a foundation some
Foundation some something which if you
were to say the universe Came From
Another Universe it came from something
else if this universe exists it can't go
back forever there has to be some first
cause okay so what is the first cause
now you said max the first cause is the
Universe I say the first cause is God
are there any more
options probably I do not think there's
any more
options either the universe came from
nothing or the universe always existed
or the universe came from
okay there's only three options okay can
the universe come from
nothing probably we have we have no
evidence of something coming from
nothing like like in our world how we
live now yeah but maybe there's
something else that we don't understand
okay but the problem is whenever we use
science logic mathematics we use in our
everyday life we've seen that this
actually works we have no reason to
doubt it exactly right so it can't be
from nothing number two either the
universe always existed or there's a God
okay there's a God behind the universe
something always existed okay good why
do you think it's the universe rather
than God and I'll explain why I believe
it's God over the universe yeah you want
to okay if the universe always existed
and
it's it's it's just a brute fact it's
always been
there then the question has to be asked
why is there movement in the universe
why are things currently moving
run out has to be asked why is there
movement in the universe why are things
currently moving you run out of energy
eventually everything will Peter down
and you'll have complete death and
complete silence it might be yeah that
might happen but it hasn't happened
because the universe is supposed to be
Eternal yeah but it can happen and it
probably will happen I think from your
perspective if the universe always
existed how old is the Universe I have
no idea Eternal yeah Eternal then that
means everything should have stopped why
because it's Eternal okay well you get a
point infin and then needs to be so look
what Ali was referring to is what is
more probable and what he said makes a
lot of sense if you go by probabilities
information comes from a source design
comes from a designer something comes
from something it doesn't come from
nothing okay so if you add all of those
things up collectively God makes much
more sense then even Universal but then
God has to come from something no
because it's a necessary being and then
that's the thing and that's not that's
illogical for me no it can't because the
thing is everything has a sign point but
you already agreed you already agreed
Haven Way by way you
did he told me it can't go back forever
you told me I told you exactly if God
exists then we can look then you can ask
if you say you know what God exists then
we can talk about who created God or if
God do got is there a creator for God
you you sorry you have heard that this
this North theory if you go like if you
say go north now yeah like okay I keep
going north but at one point you will be
at the North Pole right okay yeah and
then going north doesn't make any sense
like how how can it go any more nor well
exactly the point so how could you have
an infinite regress of depend Universe
the universe like you what happens
before
Universal nothing it's doesn't mean
anything no no no no you can't say does
mean anything you need to say that you
cannot have an infinite regress of
dependent things the universe is
dependent I I I think that we have the
same because like I don't think that the
that the Universe started everything and
that God started everything I don't I
don't think that those things are so
different things we know the universe
began to exist exactly yeah exactly if
the universe began to exist something
gave rise to it but God must have began
to exist okay we can okay firstly do you
accept the universe began to exist yeah
I age age if the universe began to exist
something gave rise to it would you
agree with that
no don't don't know okay no no one
second no one second one second you said
I accept that everything that begins to
exist has a
cause oh having a discussion he's an
atheist we're trying to prove that God
exists conversation about God existing
we're trying to prove that God exists I
don't think God that's good no I don't
know exist but then I don't think God
okay so I don't think so we're having a
discussion you can listen to it if you
want no I don't me ever help me okay so
so so the argument is following you said
the universe began to exist if the
universe began to exist that means one
at one moment of time it came to
existence okay what gave rise to that
okay you and God didn't let's look qu it
God I'm just asking a question what gave
rise to it what um something random we
don't we don't know yet that's the thing
we don't know if it began to exist you
can't say something random what gave
rise to it we don't know but but but but
you know one second standard no standard
you know okay then why do Let's cross
the road I don't want to look left and
right just go straight no no no no no
please please please don't ask please
and just do a w just say look I I didn't
push me yet let's go there and but
you're certain you see you will never do
that this is why we're saying Max why
double standards when it comes to your
day-to-day life everything is certain I
wake up in the morning I know where my
shirt is I know what I'm going to wear I
know what I'm going to eat I know what
I'm going to do everything is certain
when it comes to the most rational
logical thing nah all things are
possible but you know because brain
isn't made that the universe doesn't
have to make sense for us logic needs to
make sense to you not the universe no
the universe doesn't have to make sense
to you we're not created I'm not only
about universe universe doesn't make
sense to me no no no what I know is that
Universe began to exist I don't need to
know everything about the Universe I
know nothing about the universe all I
need to know is the following if the
universe began to exist it has a cause
that cause has to be either uncaused or
but it might not be that simple that's
the thing no no see what you're doing
why do you not apply I just want atheist
to be consistent when you wake up
tomorrow wake up tomorrow for example
you said with chance all things can
happen okay is there a chance you're a
lamp poost uh very little no no no no no
why no no no no you say TR or are
possible yeah if I said to you maybe you
are a blue rhin who lives in Mars This
is just your different form possible
yeah possible okay good is it possible
that you are a um a sign like you know
sign board board is is there a chance
you're a burger no I don't think so why
not why not why not because because we
created it thought that was thank you
you see what you do you use your logical
rationality to say can't be a burger but
when it comes to God all things are
possible that's not consistency but but
but why can you I think there's
something I think there's something
deeper here I don't think it's a logical
argument I think there's maybe you had a
bad experience with God or something
this can't be logical or rational you
know why anyone CU we use science
science we use uniformity stability to
do science in order the reason you hold
if you don't mind me holding your cup
the reason you're holding this I'm okay
I'm going to be of a diet you
are okay the reason you're holding this
is because you are certain that it
wouldn't explode the reason wear exactly
the reason you put your jacket on is
because you know it's not going to
randomly turn into an elephant that's
that's order which means if we didn't
have this we could never do science when
you come and say it can come from
nothing then why do I walk and be like
elephant just popped into existence a
woman just turned into an ant I turned
into a chocolate he becomes a burglar
because we would never be able to do
science because science measures things
how can you measure and come to
certainties when things that exploding
imagine a science experiment and before
he does the experiment he's like okay
there's a cause and effect oh it just
turned to a burger oh I'm a I'm I'm
cheese now this do you get what I'm
trying to say exactly but isn't the
thing about here is that it comes with
like the how how many years we going
like irrelevant you put in a perspective
like given a million years how I can
actually turn into a burger if you put
an apple into a box you close it
completely but are can you be a burger
instantly now no of course good so what
I'm saying is that is you you just what
you did there is a logical rational
answer but something that is far greater
than that which is that the Universe
from nothing you're saying no much more
complicated then that means it requires
more of a a possibility that it came
from something then You' being a burger
there is more chance of you being a
burger than the universe coming from
nothing more chance of you being a
burger than the universe com from
nothing yes is true there is it has to
be because DNA has information it
requires intelligence well what does
intelligence come from comes from like I
don't know from from the what's more
likely you know what what is more more
likely is that we like we humans has
always believed in religion you know we
have always have Gods where does that
come from why do we have this innate
disposition to believe in a God why why
why not why not want to because we want
to explain the universe works you want
to understand no cuz our brain logically
says something must have caused it no I
don't agree with that no no no agree why
do we then have the inclination of
believing in God then sorry where does
this inclination of in God come from
people want to explain things like where
are we so the best it's called influence
to the best explanation okay yes which
means the most logical rational thing is
what Universe began to exist something
was there but but in the beginning like
for a couple like a million like 100
years ago thousand years ago we believe
that like in Sweden we believed in the
uh OD Odin and and we were as certain as
you guys are as certain as you guys are
now that God is the one true God they
were certain that Odin exists so as
what's the attri to Odin who's Odin tell
me the attrib that's their name for God
Pagan God we have we having many
different gods no no no no no what you
have many gods good so this is why we
say the the necessary being that we're
talking about cannot be them like
Christians come and say Jesus is God we
say Jesus was a man a man is dependent
completely true is it it is no they
believe that they believe Jesus Is God
yeah he's he's God and uh God Son of God
yeah we say he cannot be God because
he's dependent anything that's dependent
we don't worship the one we worship has
to be independent because anything
that's dependent is in the universe but
but you are certain of that now you
certain I am certain I have evidences
toward it that's funny thing but you're
also that they were as certain as you
are now before that Odin exist there
there's and in in a thousand years we
will have another religion that we
believe and think that this is the truth
and this is the only truth false beliefs
that can cause you false beliefs can
cause you to survive for example if I
can say now
why why is not your belief false because
we have evidence very simple I can prove
why Allah Allah is not a man or a human
being or okay we say that the Universe
began to exist if the universe began to
exist the universe is dependent you
cannot have an infinite regress of
dependent things you need a being that
is independent self-sufficient that gave
rise to the UN un which means look this
argument and this arum is Allah let me
tell you why because if the universe
began to exist that means this being has
the power of the will to bring the
universe to existence if there's is
there information in our
universe it has to be the all knowing is
there Energy power in our universe it
has to be the all powerful is there
Injustice in our universe it has to be
the most just that who Allah that's who
Allah is that is our evidence because
when you look at a painting you know
things about a painting looking at the
uh paint you know for example somebody
made it that person is clever he's good
at what he does just by looking at a
painting there is so many things you
know about the painter so my argument is
the following we look at Universe I have
DNA DNA is information information
reques intelligence that intelligence
has to be the one who brought the
universe he has to be the all knowing
that's why we say Allah you have
evidences so the thing you need evidence
thing you do this for a living no I
understand and I'm not look I'm not here
to win an I'm not make you look I'm just
saying you have all the best Arguments
for your C you know rational but if I am
wrong I would like someone to correct me
I don't want I'm not here to just talk
for the sake of it if someone can come
and
say I would like to see that and I'm not
saying it look I I genuinely I'm not
here to act smart I know better I'm
genuinely trying to have a discussion
I'm sorry if it comes across like
that I'm not here I'm I'm learning and
and in our religion we are not not to be
arrogant I genuinely I'm not coming to
like I know better than you I'm smarter
just I'm saying that the most rational
logical explanation for our universe
coming has to be a Creator that's what
I'm coming so forgive me if I came
across like I know it I don't know don't
that's my teacher I learned from him is
that your
teacher okay well I don't think so I
think but you're better in this because
like I I do listen to your videos and I
do listen to all because I think it's
interesting I think it's that's why I
like talking to people like you because
it's some topic because I I don't
understand it I'm talking a lot with my
girlfriend
she's actually Muslim so we talk a lot
about that you
knowes have you read the Quran before
I've read some parts of it very little
but not too much you know so I think
it's I understand like I read like there
was the Swedish author who translated it
and I read some verses and I understand
like it's God is the the oil olive oil
in the in the in the in the desert by
the finest Olive Tree by the finest
Olive and that's verse in the Quran yeah
it's a verse in Quran and and that made
me think okay that's what God is for you
it's like the
most we believe he's a Creator and and
it's is very like even when it comes to
that you know if I if I today said to
you Max yeah if I say to you I'm going
to give you £5,000 every day here's this
Mansion you can live in it here's the
cars you can drive them no problem thank
you very much you will make the rues
because you are no I would not I would
say to no problem would you not thank me
yeah yeah when I call you would you not
pick up yeah okay why because I I'm
grateful you are grateful okay be so let
me ask you a question if I give you 10
billion pound but you're going to die
tomorrow would you take it no why
because I wouldn't be able to spend them
a live CU your life that you live for to
wake up tomorrow is more precious so to
me if God is the one that gives me that
life it is far more precious and if
somebody gives you £5,000 a day you'll
be grateful and thank to him so to me
The Logical rational thing is that if
God created me he feeds me he sustains
me my heart beats I don't tell my heart
to beat when I'm sleeping or even I'm
awake right now I don't tell my heart
beat beat or when I'm sleeping my lungs
every
atom that means if that Creator exists
he controls everything he deserves for
me to worship Him okay based on that
just the way when I give you money and
give you a mansion in these cars you'll
say you know what Ali Ali is a good guy
man wherever you go you're going to say
no no no no Ali is a good guy because of
what I've done for you let alone we
worship God not because of what he does
but because of who he is yeah anyways
yes he wants to talk don't blame me
sorry about that talking no no sorry
sorry thank you can I just take a
picture yeah sure it's a
pleasure he's going to beat you up
man you also have a good conversation
will I be on YouTube now oh yeah yeah oh
yeah it's it's lovely talking to you
yeah very nice guy you too man it was
really
and